[Música]
susana pessoa nova veneza sistema a voz
ea questão do envelhecimento é o que
oferece comum e nesse momento o sexto
país mais ele sim do outro mas fundo das
nações unidas poderemos vir a ser o
terceiro país mais feliz se isso é um
problema apenas 14
no entanto acham que ele será uma versão
pornô
e aí sim as portas não vai funcionar
entre as trinta segundos para pensar em
si próprio enquanto velho
pensei em vocês como 80 e 90 com o mesmo
senhor imagina ser difícil imaginar que
estava perdendo um rosto que segundo um
estudo de outra loja uma enquanto em
cada quatro pessoas mais velhas passo
que ele será o princípio do fim
por outro lado quando sua forma pode
haver um período de vida até hoje em
kiev
imaginem o que as necessidades nessa
galera é imaginar para fim que é que é o
princípio do fim absoluto é realmente
transforma se numa grande mal na bola e
trabalhar nós achamos que não é uma
missão mas sim superpoder claro podendo
mais dor nos olhos
nossa pele lê o governo muito nosso
conceito está se a olhar esta senhora
pensar assim é crível deve viver uma
vida plena
muitos filmes uma história de vida
normal e incriminou fez o seu trabalho e
seu marido a conhecer alguém a vida dos
[Música]
meus filhos e fazer orações
saio de casa sozinha gosto ela
tendências
ela é um anão minha experiência como
cumprir para ensinar as duas só com o
rosto de uma campanha já teve uma
exposição do mude museu do design e da
moda com uma performance que ela fez
[Música]
para pessoas com mais necessidades um
dos nosso lixo e como a maioria das
pessoas que nos visitam sábado o projeto
acho que é altamente criativo fazendo as
coisas incríveis
às vezes batem na porta pessoas contendo
40 50
toda a gente já sabe onde eles gostam
mas já fala em que não sejam em novos
computadores há quem considere que não
ocorre se espalhado para ser ator
australiano ser complexa como é viver o
site sítio muito sentido de dignificar
os que ousaram dizer nada como com cinco
equipes boxe merece e não nós tínhamos
vergonha muitas vezes cheira nunca dizia
foi lá não é
pronto já não é muito atrativo dizer que
está esse tempo e quando vê nessas
coisas nossas avós um órgão nessa mesma
final
errei é daquelas pessoas que acham que
só obriga a que as mulheres são bonitas
neste fácil neste espaço nós fazemos é
que todas as pessoas com mais idade
podem a e trabalho gt é uma porta aberta
todos os dias todos os estados mostrando
ampla
lá ia ser revistas elas tomaram os
projetos criativos estão acontecendo -
parecer coleções é manufaturado na mão
aparecer projetos específicos nós
fazemos valer menos aos participam num
quer enquanto que é mas foi um fato
participar em tese essas experiências
transformadoras e como dona precisão que
elas têm na europa mas também é
essencial que a comunidade também
trabalhamos para ser como é que
participar de um evento pra cá municipal
- rua e explorarmos da primavera qual
frida kahlo que e assim nada se reflete
na tabela a partida que dará um show
para turistas
muitas vezes ficam no nosso espaço aqui
é se quando kashur e e ele vai aprender
robôs é mudar é tentar incentivar e
aprender o estado da economia é sorrir
sempre fui chamado no show do turismo eo
ainda certo é que usar termos nosso
grupo está na voz
algumas falam inglês e fazer isso
aconteceu finalmente neste novo shopping
que transformaram positivo hiper super
não há ninguém é posso fazer essa
transição e um incrível e não é preciso
falar em junho ficou em linguagens o fat
é uma linguagem unidade ii e os gaúchos
também o fator social mesma mensagem aos
constroem está a fazer outra coisa
continua a mostrar por fora está a
construir também poder em nós próprios e
nas nossas custas
os outros que assim que as nossas avós
passa o seu testemunho ou diminuía ou
olímpico você já tenha de esperar raiva
como um fator positivo como um
superpoder com uma coisa maravilhosa que
as gerações mais novas devem já é que
estamos a falar não anda
o design é a globo se mostrado que esses
ele na geral a não trago sabe fazer é em
melhor eo mais incrível é que o colapso
na cidade e as pessoas vinham para
visitar 49 escombros após dois voam pela
estrutura eo linguagem ficarmos muito e
e montagem de sal e mais incrível fez
pessoas crê chegarem aos quais crer
pedagógico encontraram 19 será então não
vamos embora liso e fazer sucesso que a
gente conhece né moto nem nada
a autoimagem ao que hoje também querem
perceber a experienciar nem ao lado das
nossas não gosta não fácil ter gosto de
tudo que coisa tudo 90 regional nós
criamos e fazemos e perdemos nosso deus
não vão negociar saiu dos meus produtos
tributados trabalhados em tear sejam
serigrafias há um senso de cobrir
segundo roxo que é muito estética ou
seja tem de mostrar quais são as
tendências dos objetos que vão agora ser
verídico
quais são as duas unidades quais são os
materiais
quem não podemos fazer diferente muitas
vezes é lustrosos é objetivos buscados
fizeram com que eram mais novas com
técnicas antilhas e todos em conjunto
engenheiros novas coisas novas coisas
possam surpreender
esse sim vai bem interessantes e dona
júlia estávamos a fazer a nossa segunda
coleção de objetos
queremos fazer almofadas trabalhadas em
ampliar e eu pedi que elas confiança em
mim pra fazermos franjas e dona julia
achou que as praias é uma coisa horrível
então todos os dias ela fazia saber
fazer frente a ser horrível e que o
trabalho que ela estava fazendo durante
um mês não estou empregada e eu tentando
incentivar aula quase em todas as
sociais da camada de ozônio está a ficar
maravilhoso maravilhoso levar o que
acontece quando ela teve dificuldade de
fazer o fiar até o fim mas ela ficou na
dúvida diz vou apresentar esse ano vou
fazer isso até o fim quando um fado foi
montada quando foi feita a exposição foi
uma das primeiras rodadas a ser vendidas
e obra termine esse pra meninos usar né
afinal você tenha razão
e olha sustentar o aumento e este é um
certame é muito interessante que tirar
as avós da sua zona de conforto ou seja
no nosso espaço
nós não estamos a construir as coisas
por nós próprios estamos a construir um
tipo de cunha e muitas das coisas que é
hoje que estão a fazer são também
inovadoras elas nunca fizeram e nunca
experimentaram e há este risco de fazer
uma coisa nova e não correr bem mas é
importante aceitar este risco
este desafio bastante divertido foi uma
série de flores de papel feitas em
cartolina para um evento em carne que um
decorador português precisava para fazer
uma festa
não vi ninguém quisesse fazer um lago
hoje nós não sabíamos fazer as ruas mas
como precisamos de financiamento para o
projeto
vamos fazer as flores vamos aprendendo a
internet fizemos alguns testes ea
verdade é que os fãs ficarão prontas
ficaram maravilhosas nós aprendemos uma
técnica nova que não sabe me a e
engenharia já podemos dizer que fazemos
força do papel este exemplo que o
estrago é que ele é muito querido pra
mim porque nós fomos desafiados para
fazer um merchandising do festival de
música portuguesa que é o bom som semsur
está há dois anos atrás tivemos este
perfil e colocar minha casa e como somos
cheios embora lá durante seis meses
pontos uma vez por mês esta ideia e eu
levava comigo algumas a voz para
desempenharmos os objetos e tentarmos
perceber o que poderíamos criar
juntamente com a população
voltávamos no mês seguinte fazemos
controle de qualidade
desenvolvemos um novo objeto e assim
escrito durante seis meses
no final do festival do de todo este
trabalho que nossos inimigos bom com
nova vai trabalhar
nós trabalhamos para nos divertir que
teve para termos acesso a experiências
transformadoras todas as avós fizeram
parte deste processo tem direito de
viver o festival durante três dias e
esse foi o que foi mágico é algo quando
nós estamos juntas falamos muitas vezes
no que aconteceu e ninguém esqueça ii
que mudou durante três dias
eu não lembro nem que tivesse só para
elas sem estar a sorrir iluminado cheio
de alegria e europeu dessas mulheres não
eram velhinhas eram apenas a partilha de
filmes no festival há aqui uma delas
quero fazer é que na altura tinha 80
ah e não foi por isso que ela não estava
na linha da frente da uma da manhã num
concerto didático é saltar a e pra mim o
estrangeiro em cima do gol foi quando eu
ouvi uma rapariga bria ter cerca de 20 e
21 anos virar pra luiz que está aqui e
dizer eu quando for velha quer ser assim
e isso é o que me move é algo fácil
trabalhar todos os dias e algum faz ter
esta iniciativa que é mostrar que a
idade não é uma maldição mas é uma coisa
bela pode vir a ser um superpoder e usar
os mesmo que as gerações mais novas têm
uma certa inveja das pessoas mais velhas
porque elas podem se podem e devem ser o
nosso futuro ficou amor
nós achamos que elas são o futuro é
muito importante também que não estejam
terminadas nem cristalizadas na noção do
que sua própria pessoa ou seja se vocês
virem todo o trabalho que nós fazemos há
um esforço muito grande em brincarmos
com a autoimagem quer ser velho que quer
ser novo e como é que nós conseguimos
ter capacidade do vírus de nós próprios
sempre conhecemos coleções sempre
fazemos um evento temos esta capacidade
de brincar nos connosco próprios a este
foi antes do lançamento da nossa
primeira coisa que quero uma coleção de
metas e pentes na rua do posto negro já
dava uma série de fantasmas a serem
fotografados a para a nossa nova
campanha e muitas as pessoas que são os
nossos vizinhos que tal nunca feito nos
perguntar de que nos conhecem
riram alguns criticaram outras a voz não
viram assim umas coisas por trás das
costas que não deveriam ter feito aquilo
porque pronto para ser umas tontas
mas é muito importante é ver nossas
cabeças todas as pessoas que acham que
nós somos tontas certa maneira
acha que é tão disso é fácil fazer
coisas grandiosas como esta
isto foi uma peça que nós fizemos em
parceria com a artista brasileira mainá
bonatto por algo do museu do design e da
moda portanto uma peça comissionada por
uma exposição que se chamava tanto mal
tem que se trabalhar com a posição que o
design brasileiro eo design português
fazem isso contamina um outro também não
vai fazer uma se viesse conosco durante
três meses a não sabíamos o que ia sair
dali
acabou por ser uma espiral do link
quatro metros por quatro total membro da
não trabalha trabalha muito a questão da
palavra então criou poesias a outra
história dessas mulheres algumas
lágrimas foram derramadas por abordar
quatro metros por quatro durante dois
meses a é difícil nós tivemos medo não
conseguir mas o cec revezamento conforto
neste obrigar nos a ter certa maneira -
vamos conseguir também nos faz que
cheguei quando pessoas e o mais incrível
foi que no fim desta pessoa está pronta
todos nós sentimos que a peça não era
suficiente era preciso cobrar essas
mulheres e se sobrar um dia da inovação
e fazer uma performance e assim foi
foi uma performance que foi feita com
todas as pessoas que participaram na
peça
tínhamos este fogo antes havia música ao
vivo cada uma dessas mulheres teve um ou
dois minutos para poderem estar
presentes falar da sua alma exigir os
olhares de todas as pessoas praia onde
portantiolo durante hoje enquanto
cidadãs e não enquanto velhinhas estão
museu a não ela está aqui tão vivas têm
muito pouco cheio e tem muito para dar e
eu queria partilhar com vocês a história
revela que está ali ao pé do adversário
a nave há uns meses depois a ver comigo
estávamos a ter uma conversa como temos
muitas enquanto trabalhava
beber um copo fim ou não almoço ou
jantar faz vai da vida segundo aquela
camisa
mas a novela disse olha eu grito contar
que no dia em que nós fizemos a
performance eu estava tão cheia então
alegre tão feliz comigo próprio
quando eu cheguei a casa eu tenho sempre
uma garrafa de espumante do meu
frigorífico após ano do meu neto
empresário da minha filha e eu sentar ea
única garrafa até o fim porque eu
precisava de furarem a novela estava
emocionado ao ouvir a história
[Música]
é isso que é o trabalho trabalho não é
peça nem querer performance do trabalho
e mudar a imagem que estas mulheres saem
serrista possam acreditar sim que são
super pessoas e que elas podem guardar
até onde elas quiserem e ao mesmo tempo
mudar as revistas todas as pessoas que
acham que ser v
é o princípio do fim cerveja é o
princípio do fim da amizade tinha
imensos chang por concretizar
queria muito muito ir à holanda agora
começamos a semana passada não conseguiu
do adversário morreu há dois meses atrás
foi muito duro para nós ela seja tudo
aquilo que nós acreditamos que deve ser
a vida ela ganhava a vida com toda a sua
dentadura tancredi tentadas e ela queria
fazer tudo hoje e ainda quer necessito
já não tem se dado para fazer essas
coisas e ela portanto é um exemplo é um
exemplo como é que ia viver a vida
vivendo e não estava morto e vida e por
isso tudo que nós fazemos tenha
estipulado de brincadeira nós mesmos
preços mulheres e elas parecem beatas
não é a voz vai trabalhar na organização
uma vez é uma porta da onu no país das
maravilhas essas mulheres são metas
estão sempre tira tem um mundo todo pela
frente todo isso nós fazemos todos os
dias quando já tínhamos que tem de se
maquiar
quando é obrigada por um lance na cabeça
com rumores a qual fazemos este chutem
de moda e expomos às vezes de maneira
mais louca entretanto elas olharem para
si próprios como orgulho e pararem de
olhar para aquelas fotografias quando
tinham 20 anos em dizer ah eu era tão
bonita não era falha você evita agora
agora porque a doença vem dentro da
doença vai na alma nós podemos ser doida
de ser cuidadosos mas é brasil e salva
vidas ou viver muitos anos e faz com que
a gente seja assim alegre
eu não estarei aqui mesmo com dores
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nós acreditamos que as mulheres com
história são as mais importantes e eu
tudo isso apenas quatro e que tinham
coisas e se vocês eu deixava o torcedor
aqui um desafio que era hoje liguei hoje
com os pais os vossos avós as duas
testemunhas quem não quer ver falcão
velhota manhã mas pensa em que o show
futuro e não o passado não sejam
digeridos
eu chamo o nosso futuro e temos todos
parar por os nossos vezes à margem da
vida é preciso investir por favor em
vista das pessoas mais velhas e vamos
deixar com um vídeo dos bons sons porque
acho q vao por mil palavras obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]